conversation but uh mickey are the d.o.t
they are here i don't know if you want
me to pull them in now or if we wanted
to do the script to start us
off and then i could pull them in here
but i can grab now if you'd like yeah
that would be fine
um but uh we'll
thank you what i will
do this okay let me let me try again
thank you as chair of division two of
the house finance committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this public meeting is pertaining to
the department of transportation
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order
i am confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules
and rsa 91 a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
should email lba underline
fiscal at leg dot state
dot nh dot us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this
meeting shall be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know
law so representative lynn would you
please um take the attendance
yes uh thank you madam chair uh
first uh representative bucco yes thank
you
uh representative tom bucco i'm here in
conway at my home and there's no one
else in the house
thank you uh representative danielson is
not present representative heath
mary heath here and i'm at home um in
manchester new hampshire and
i'm here all by myself my husband's gone
off to the grocery store
all right thank you i'm representative
bob lynn i'm here at my home in windham
and i'm alone in the room but my wife is
present in the house uh representative
murray
good morning kate murray here in
newcastle i'm here with my dog and all
together now david's in the basement
thank you uh representative petrie
guys thank you uh joe petry
i am uh home alone in farmington
the dog is still here though
you and representative berger
yes i am uh at my home in uh
in kearsarge uh i think my husband is
someplace in the house i'm not sure
but uh he'll be in and out thank you all
right
thank you representative lind and i
would like to
uh welcome the folks from uh
d.o.t and i'm looking forward to
uh hearing what you have to say
uh i will tell you that yesterday
we talked to the uh the safety people
and um listen to what they had to say
and in particular about um
what their draw was going to be on the
um highway fund so we've got a lot of
revenues that have been coming in
um we've not seen the same sort of
effect on the road toll
as we have on many of the other areas
within the within revenue so
uh i got your briefing and i'm
ready for whomever wants to start
okay thank you good morning um madam
chair members of the committee
thank you for this opportunity to come
back and spend some time
going through some of the details of our
budget
in preparation for today we were
reflecting upon the questions that we
received at our last session
and so there's a couple of items that we
thought warranted further discussion
and so marie mullen our director of
finance has put together a presentation
she's going to pull it up on the screen
and
as with our last presentation both
myself as commissioner um
and then chris wojcik's deputy
commissioner will be presenting
and marie will do sort of a deeper dive
when it comes to the
the details of our accounting and bill
cass our assistant commissioner is here
to answer any questions that you might
have when it comes to projects or the
work that we perform
so the first item that we wanted to
focus on is the highway fund
waterfall just to make sure that
especially for any new members
you understand which funds are
restricted
and which ones are unrestricted and
available for
use in the budget and um while this
chart on the screen is rather busy
we're going to focus um just on the
bolded headings and marie's going to
walk you through the waterfall i think
representative lin this will help you
understand why as we discussed at the
last meeting
we have to continue to work on design
and construction projects
even at times when our operations are
stretched very thin
it's all to do with how accounts are
restricted
and intended for a certain purpose um so
with that i'll turn it over to marie
good morning let me make sure i'm
unmuted
i am unmuted okay good morning everyone
madam chair and thank you for having us
back again
um this first slide is it's a history of
the road toll and motor vehicle fees
this is something as the commissioner
said we like to
present so that folks can understand
first
the road toll the gas tax the 22.2 cents
that the state collects
how that gets broken down and and where
that goes
each year so
first of all um by law 12
of the gross revenue that comes in from
the road toll
goes out to block grant aid it gets
distributed to
municipalities throughout the state
so that's the first thing off the top so
that's approximately 2.7 cents of the
22.2 cents
uh then in law or rsa 239
is the betterment law where 88
of 3 cents goes to betterment
so it's that 12
comes off the top for block grant aid so
that's why you can see it's
2.6 cents and not 3 cents because the
block grant aid comes out of the top of
that so
approximately 2.6 cents is restricted
revenue that comes to the department of
transportation
for betterment that is used for paving
uh bridge projects various repairs
throughout the state
it's primarily used for paving and
culvert work um that we
that we do need to need to maintain and
repair on our roads
this funding goes towards um
a majority of our um non-fed eligible
roads so
federal funds are not able to be used
for maintenance and repair so
these funds are needed for
those non-federal eligible roads and
also for the maintenance and repairs on
our roads
because federal funds can only be used
for
more permanent repairs and that type of
thing so
they don't allow us to use it on
maintenance so this betterment funding
is extremely important to maintain
the you know our roads and bridges in
the state
sp 367 um many of you
may be aware back in 2014 that was the
bill number
where 4.2 increase in the road toll
was passed through the legislature and
the governor at that time
again you see 3.7 cents here that's
because 12 percent comes off the top
and is part of this block grant aid here
so 3.7 of that
goes to sb 367 and a later slide will
show you
how the waterfall of sb 367 and how
those funds get distributed in what
they're being used
for so we will talk about that later on
in the presentation
and then lastly the remainder the 13.2
cents
[Music]
ends up being the the unrestricted
revenue
that goes towards operations for the
department of safety
for dot and other agencies that draw on
the highway fund
including cost of collections for the
road toll
then you have the motor vehicle fees
that are collected by the department of
safety
um again the 12 block grant comes off of
the top of those
um that gross and so then 88
is used for um again
for the is the unrestricted piece
that gets used for operations for dot
department of safety again and the other
agencies
so um so we like to show you know
in this history how that breakdown um
of those total revenues that come in
what portion
is going directly back to the
municipalities
is being used by safety and other
agencies and
by dot so you can see over time
um you know these percentages have
shifted
um you know at one point dot was at 65
percent
now we're at like 58 59 percent
um and some of these others have
increased block grant is now up to 14
going out to the municipalities um
so i don't know if there's any questions
on this but we just
you know wanted to show where all where
the road toll and these
unrestricted motor vote motor vehicle
fees
i i do have a question um
one over on your last column there that
says
uh for nhdot
percent for nhd dot um
is that the decline because of the
change we made
in costa collections or
is it some other area that is
um causing the drop um i think over time
it's been the the way that the
it's been determined how the but how the
budget works um
um i believe the department of state
safety state police and others
you know at one point when the general
fund was in
um poorer condition than the highway
fund was
there you know there were highway funds
moved over to support state police in
other areas
and some of that has now come back the
other way as you can see it
at one point it was dot was about 50
um back in 2012 uh dot was about 50
percent of that
it's come back up i think that you know
more general funds have been put into
the state police and that's been kind of
reversed a little bit
but i think that's where some of it was
uh the cost of collections has always
come out of
the highway fund um so
it it back in like 2012 or 2014 it was
just
the revenue was just called something
else but it's always come out of the
highway fund
okay thank you representative murray you
have a question
yes thank you so much i suspect i'm
supposed to already know this but i'll
be darned if i can dredge it up this
morning
where are these percentages uh where who
determines these percentage
divisions this
these are based on actual expenditures
at
for those years but those are those are
determined based on the budget and how
the budget is
appropriated at that time at that year
during the biennium
so it's dependent upon you know the
legislature the governor at the time and
how they've
determined those funds should be used
there is an
rsa um rsa 6
that requires a certain percentage
be provided to dot and other agencies
so that rsa actually i believe it's rsa
requires that at least 74 percent
be contributed to the department of
transportation
and the department of safety can have no
more than 26 percent and other
agencies can have no more than one
percent so
there is something in law that requires
a certain percentage
and when you're looking at dot
percentages um
because the block grant aid goes through
our budget
those two percentages get added together
for that rsa
so as marie explained it's like
currently in statute
it says that no more than 26 can go to
safety but i think we touched on this
last time
as we finalize the budget that's one of
the checks that we always do
and as you can see in the past at times
they've suspended that law and changed
the percentages
so madam chair is that something that
we'll be discussing or no
uh absolutely okay thank you
yeah i'm sure mickey's usually right on
top of that so i'm sure
mickey is probably already been looking
are there any uh further questions
uh are you i have one more are you
getting any
feedback from the towns about the fact
that the block grants are going to go
down
this year because just the money has not
yeah i think we've had um some concern
about that commissioner i don't know if
you've heard
more i don't get direct calls on that
type of thing but i do think
i think last year because the block
grant
allocations that are made to the
municipalities are based on the prior
year's revenues
when we um awarded the dollars
um during the pandemic it was based on
the prior year's revenues they didn't
see a reduction
but certainly at this point going
forward based on where revenues are
trending
there would be concern that's one of the
reasons that we're advocating at the
federal level
for further relief dollars or stimulus
dollars for transportation purposes
because then we could hopefully
um try and restore some of this funding
and the minimum get back to
what we have been able to spend in the
past
heath you have a question oh thank you
madam chair i did not realize
that you had that um drag
so do you have to appropriate more
um then really you have are able to
based on um what's happened
with uh people just not driving and your
revenues are not coming in the way you
expect
i guess my question is will this further
put you into more deficit
because of those block grants that have
to go to municipalities
no representative um because it's 12 of
the revenues that we collect
if the revenues go down then we
allocate less than was budgeted okay i
think what's happened in the past is
when revenues trend above projection we
then go to fiscal
to be given the authority to distribute
additional money to make sure the cities
mary the the problem is that the 12
this year is going to be quite a bit
less than what it
has been in the past um
and it will be the same for uh next year
since uh uh commissioner indicated that
it was based on prior year
for uh distribution so i expect
that we
we the representatives will be um
hearing from our cities and towns
about you know how could you nasty folks
our grants but you know we just need to
explain to them
that it's based on revenue
and maybe they should drive a little
what we did discuss at the end of the
last legislative session
was if we as dot were to receive
stimulus funding or through
reauthorization
be given dollars where we had more
flexibility we explained that
we are reliant on the betterment and the
state funds
to both support the municipalities as
well as to do work on certain
types of roadway primarily what we call
tier three and four roads that aren't
eligible for federal funding
but if there was additional federal
dollars provided with more flexibility
and where we could use them
then certainly as part of the budget
process if dot was receiving more direct
funding
through federal sources then we could
adjust the block grant percentage maybe
for the upcoming budget
but right now there's no guarantees of
federal funding that's certainly
something that we
um you know shouldn't be
until we understand what dollars might
be available um
but maybe in hb2 there would be an
opportunity to change some of the
percentages just for this biennium
if federal dollars materialize that
would help us out
so those are all things that we're
tracking closely and as we advocate
um both through our delegation and
through
the associations that we're part of we
keep advocating that we need flexibility
we don't just want an increase in
federal funding for traditional
federal uses we need to be a little bit
more flexible
to ensure that we can continue to honor
our commitments to
cities and towns
so uh when you were in dc
advocating did you did you get any
positive response or were they just uh
typical uh senators that sat there and
looked at you well the senators were
primarily talking about re-authorization
that day
and which would be the next federal
funding bill um
so we're expecting that there would be
limited flexibility
when they pass a new surface
transportation bill what we're hoping
for is
as soon as the relief discussions are
concluded and they start talking about
an infrastructure package that's meant
more for stimulus
then that's where we might be given the
flexibility um just as
you know the 41 million that we received
in relief dollars in december of 2020
um those dollars we have that latitude
to use them for
operations and maintenance which is why
in the governor's budget you see that
transfer reducing our draw on the
highway fund
so it's the my testimony was more about
long-term funding and making sure that
we have sustainable sources of federal
revenue that we can count on
because that way as we do our 10-year
plan we have a better sense of
what size our program will be but then
we also are
advocating for this you know
infrastructure stimulus
that would have more of a near-term
benefit and hopefully that's where they
build in the flexibility
are there any further questions okay
so last time when we came before you we
touched on
some of these items but we thought it
warranted revisiting
um how dollars have been
moving in and out of the highway fund to
help balance the budget in prior
biennium so with that marine do you want
to explain
what the charts on this slide show
yeah so on on this side slide you
probably remember last time we went
through
um some of the um you know
revenue like the 30 dollar surcharge
back in 2010 2011
um that was put in place and then was
repealed that was to help
with the deficit at the time in the
highway fund
there were some other one-time areas
such as the retro
turnpike toll credits as you know we
match
our federal program with toll credits so
at that time we had been using state
match on some projects and we were
allowed to retroactively go back
and collect the federal funds and return
the state funds
so we did that for that period of time
that we could and then of course there
was the i-95
sale of the bridge between maine and new
hampshire
to the turnpike system and
the revenue from that transaction
was included in the budget originally
that was supposed to be a 20-year note
it was supposed to be paid over 20 years
by the turnpike system
but was advanced to help balance the
highway fund
and as you can see it was paid off over
six years
um so at that time we had those
additional revenues
and i just want to point out that this
is the unrestricted revenue so
we're on that previous chart we had
included
betterment and sb 367. these revenues do
not include that because those are
restricted
funds so this just includes the
unrestricted portion
and then this um this is just um
something else that we had talked about
we didn't but we didn't actually have
the you know we i just verbally talked
about the
the numbers and stuff there were some
other
one-time sources that were
put into the highway fund to help
balance the highway fund
so we talked about the first three on
the previous slide
back in 2016 and 2017 we
also had 8.3 million each year
that was used from the sb
367 4.2 gas tax so prior to
dot entering the the loan
with um with the tiffy alone with the
federal government
we were we used a portion of that
revenue
to for the operating budget for dot
d.o.t
so that was included in here and and
once we went into that loan we were
unable to
use it for operations anymore because we
have other covenants on that loan
so that's why you'll see it for that
year in
2017 to balance the 2018-2019 budget
there was 13.9 million of general funds
put into the highway fund again in
2020 there was 4 million and
currently in this budget um there's 8.1
million
from the general fund and as you may
remember last time we discussed
that was um those were funds that were
um general funds that were provided to
the department
for red list bridge repairs we were able
to
identify federal funds on the the last
bridge
so we've lapsed so those funds have been
will be lapsed and will be transferred
to the highway fund to help balance the
highway fund
and then again the federal relief funds
um from the end of december for the
crrsaa
act a coronavirus relief act
i'll just leave it that at that we
received 41 million dollars in relief
funds
that um for lost revenue that have been
has been incurred because of covid so
that has been
infused into the highway fund as well to
help balance the highway fund
um so all of these one-time sources have
been able you know have been used and
utilized in the past
to help balance the fund and balance the
the work that needs to be done for
department of transportation department
of safety
and the other agencies that draw on the
fund
this is part of the reason that you see
that change in the percentage of highway
funds going to different
departments as well depending on how
these general fund dollars are budgeted
whether they go directly to an agency or
whether it's a transfer into the highway
fund
that's part of the reason for the
fluctuation in addition to
um the costs of doing business
fluctuating over time and the
legislature choosing to budget dollars
does anyone have any questions before i
move on
yes uh representative murray has a
question
thank you madam chair um just a little
hopeful thinking um you know
i see that big drop down to 2023
um any hope on the horizon
about what may change in 2023 with
so department of safety who collects the
revenue has been doing presentations for
ways and means
on what we're anticipating for highway
fund revenue
uh throughout this next biennium but
then also we're starting conversations
around
what the future looks like before this
meeting began
uh the committee were having a
discussion around
how the real estate market is doing very
well in new hampshire and
how a lot of folks from out of state
have moved into new hampshire
and if those individuals can continue to
telework
we're going to continue to see different
commuting patterns so that's
what our primary concern is and i think
we touched on this last time
but it's it's challenging for us in the
transportation profession at the moment
to anticipate how businesses are going
to react post pandemic
movements it's great as we talked about
last time for individuals
in that teleworking gives them more
flexibility and better work-life balance
um you know we talked about the
expansion of telehealth
um as well as online purchasing
and then also online higher education
and all of those factors will impact our
long-term
traffic patterns so that's why we're
starting conversations with chambers of
commerce
and i actually am speaking at the
business industry association next week
so that we can
determine how we can best work with
industry and
businesses to understand what their
work environment environments going to
be in the future and what options are
going to provide
i see no further questions so if you
wouldn't mind
we can go forward
so as marie mentioned earlier um we were
remiss last time that we did not include
this slide with the waterfall
for sb 367. and so in that pink chart
that you saw in the first slide we
talked about the overall
waterfall of all the um highway fund
revenue
but this slide shows you specifically
what our commitments are
through senate bill 367. so marie do you
want to
do the deep dive on this one yeah
absolutely
um so um sb 367
um increased the road toll by 4.2 cents
but dedicated it
to certain areas um
so the first area that by law that
based on this waterfall that comes out
of this is the block grant aid so 12
percent
is again is distributed to the cities
and towns directly
next as part of the law it is to cover
any debt service costs related to i-93
so um in the law it was agreed that 200
million could be
bonded or loan or or et cetera
we engaged in a tiffy alone with
the depa with the federal government um
and that tiffy alone
um what we were able to get the rural
interest rate so we had an all-in
interest cost of 1.09 percent on that
loan
it was far cheaper than bonding or any
other financing mechanism
so we we entered into that loan so
the second requirement is interest in
principal payments
for that for that loan so you can see
the schedule here and what we you know
what we've done
is during the construction phase we are
paying
interest only on the project
um it it was just opened in december of
2020 to four lanes
um so we were able to defer um
and paying principal for four years
after completion of construction
and then upon that we need to start
paying principal
in fiscal year 2026. so you can see
we're paying interest only and during
that time
those funds go to other places in the
waterfall so as part of the waterfall
state aid bridge so aid for municipal
bridges
get 6.8 million per year
and then as i had stated before that in
2016-17 there were a couple of areas
where we put it towards the operating
budget
but after the state aid bridge then the
last
area that the the funds would flow to
are
the betterment program so
we have pledged as part of the tiffy
alone that we will
do rural paving and bridge repairs
and that by cove by having that covenant
and making that
dedication to doing rural paving and
bridge repairs that's how we were able
to get
that low interest rate we were able to
get the rural interest rate
so um as you can see um you know we have
about
20 to 23 million dollars depending on
the revenue and what's left over as it
as it flows down to the betterment that
we've been putting into
paving each year and uh redless bridges
um so for the great
is this in addition to
the um money from the road toll
or the the dollar value that you showed
us before
for betterment is it that dollar value
plus
this for betterment yes that's correct
betterment is a
separate amount it's three cents out of
that
out of that full 22.2 cents it's a
separate three cents and this
four on top of that so perhaps marie do
you want to go back to the first slide
yep so this clearly shows that the the
gross
road toll is 22.2 cents
so there's 2.6 going to betterment
then there's 3.7 of the 4.2 cents
because the 12
comes off the top goes to
um this sb 367 waterfall
and then what marie has shown you is the
deeper dive on how those dollars get
distributed
okay so it's it's it's additive
yes so the betterment is additive to
this yep
okay thank you very much the one thing i
want to
highlight is for the purposes of this
budget you know we're very confident
that revenues will continue
to sustain providing a full 6.8 million
to municipal bridges through the
state aid bridge program that's because
we're still paying the
interest only on the tifio loan um
the numbers that we are showing you for
2026 and beyond in terms of revenue
projections are very
preliminary um next year as we work on
the 10-year plan and we have more
certainty around you know how traffic
patterns are
changing a post pandemic we'll be
working to refine these numbers
um but you can see that we're now
previously
um we were forecasting a larger
amount of revenue in those out years
which would have allowed us to support
the state a bridge program at 6.8
million
annually now we're showing that if the
revenues decline
as one of our models indicates the
amount of funding available for city and
town
bridge work will be impacted as well
so it's not something to worry about for
this budget like i said because we're
still paying
interest only we have the full 6.8
million to make
sure that we follow through in our
commitments and can advance the projects
that are currently programmed
but certainly as we look to the 10-year
plan
and talk about the state a bridge
program
will be discussing this waterfall in
more detail
a conversation we'll have with your
colleagues on the public works and
highways committee
rather than division two finance
did i see one of one of the participants
with their hands
raised
okay uh chris yeah you want to make one
one more additional comment on the
future revenue
as part of um as part of an exercise to
look at the road usage fee
we hired a consultant and it's noted
down here came to systematics
in the footnote one to look at the
long-term
impact of fuel efficient vehicles on
highway fund revenue so as part of their
effort
they took a hard look and they had a
range of options
and this represents kind of the middle
middle of the
um you know in between the high and low
impact that they identified so it shows
about a percent reduction
per year in revenue
because of the increase in
fuel-efficient vehicles so
um it's certainly it's certainly a
projection um
but it comes from that study and comes
from you know their expertise in that
area
i just want to point that out for the
committee
thank you that's uh that is a
that's a good point so those are the two
industry trends we're going to be
watching both
you know the greening of the fleet and
the increase in fuel efficiency but then
also
the long-term um commuter patterns as
well so those two factors will
impact our revenue forecasts when we
look at a longer horizon
and and then in the future horizon as
well in 2035 that's when
the the rsa sunsets when the 4.2 set sun
sets
so it was a 20-year period or when the
the bonds were paid off so
this is that 20 20 35 is that 20 year
period so in 2035
currently the revenue sun sets and
there um that goes away for any
betterment or
any other road work and block grenade as
well
any other questions on the tiffia i
doubt that any of us will be
okay marie thank you uh if you want to
go oh tom you have a question
uh yes uh yes thank you madam chair so i
i just wanted to uh go back to um
how this how this program got the the
nickname of waterfall and i think that
what i remember was that um here in here
in um
2025 when we start stop when we have to
stop repaying the principal
and then the uh the money for paving and
bridge
bridge work just falls right off
am i was that correct with that yeah
that is our concern representative
um as chair umberger indicated
our betterment program is much larger
today because we have
the betterment dollars that are
restricted and then we add to them
with the tiffia pledged uh bridge repair
dollars
and so we're spending significantly more
but yes come 2026
um as we start paying the principal on
the tiffy alone
then our capacity to do work um through
the betterment program
is basically half um depending on how
the revenue projections trend
and uh you know we're fortunate
because of sb 367 and then the further
value that the tiffy alone provided
we're experiencing some of the best
pavement condition we've been able to do
an additional 23 redless bridges
with this revenue and but we are
concerned about what will happen to
condition
when uh first we start paying the
principal
um but then the other concern for the
municipalities is the fact that the
state a bridge program um
you know may shrink in size over time
and then
with sunset in 2035 and that's the only
support that we provide to cities and
towns directly for their bridge projects
thank you commissioner representative
murray
thank you this is an aside um is anyone
else hearing
chatter um like another conversation
someone's listening to another
conversation
um it's a little bit distracting
is anyone else hearing that or is it
just me yes i hear that
i think perhaps mike
yeah perhaps it's representative petrie
it's not me my mic's open but there's
there's no chatter here
oh there's i hear another conversation
going on so i was wondering if we can
all mute anyway thank you sorry to
interrupt
no problem um
so at this point we wanted to circle
back to some of our additional needs
that were not funded
um last time we spent some
of our session together talking in
detail about the fleet and in a few
moments um chris is going to
once again revisit some of those numbers
to make sure that you have the complete
picture
um so i'm going to skip over the first
two items but um
as was mentioned last time during the
last budget we were very
grateful that there was additional
funding provided for us to do some
preventative maintenance work
unfortunately some of that work did not
proceed once um
covert 19 started to impact revenues
and you know we were trying to lapse as
much uh funding as possible
and so we are still concerned that we
should be spending more
on important items such as the repair
and maintenance of guardrail
and this of course is very important
from a safety perspective
and um as well as things like
bridge washing we currently don't have
adequate funding to wash all of our
bridges
annually after the winter season to get
all the salt off them
and we certainly would like to have a
more robust program
and it's all about keeping the
infrastructure in a good state of repair
because that's the most cost effective
way
to manage those assets and then there's
several other items that
have been discussed in previous biennium
and it's disappointing that we haven't
been able to move forward
um telematic devices and equipment and
software
to help us better manage our fleet um
that's one of the items that we've put
forward several times
the other thing is as we prepare for
both new and emerging technologies and
continue
to enhance our traffic management
and we have been deploying a lot of its
devices that's intelligent
transportation devices
and um you'll see that we have
both cameras out on the highway as well
as some of those dynamic
message signs that help us communicate
reduce speed limits as an example during
snow events
and while we've been using federal funds
to install a number of those devices or
turnpike funds it was part of major
capital projects
some of that equipment does need
further repair and maintenance and so
that's another exposure that we have
and then graffiti removal i know this
committee during the last budget talked
a lot about
um some of the uh aesthetics
um and the uh
the impression that we want to give
visitors to our state and so
unfortunately you know when we are
struggling to
do the essential um routine maintenance
and ensure that we are
patching potholes keeping the highway
safe the things that don't get done as
frequently
are things like graffiti removal um and
we don't mow as frequently and such
items like that because they're
i'm certainly important in terms of the
character of our state
but you know we have to favor other work
that
supports safety and ensures that we can
keep the system running
and so one of the other things that we
had previously
asked for it and had been supported was
graffiti removal
which is very costly especially in some
of the more urban areas
where it's a challenge to keep up
and you know it's both graffiti on our
bridge abutments
as well as a number of our sound walls
and noise barriers that we have along
the highway
and then the last item is something
we've talked about again for several
biennium
um the conway bypass project
um i believe uh cherumburger bill cass
as you requested did reach out and you
had a conversation about this project
but the conway bypass was a 10-year plan
project
that was advanced in design and
construction and but the traffic volumes
never really grew as expected
and so it was determined that given our
limited federal funding
um it wasn't prudent to move forward and
construct that project as planned
so we have to pay back the federal
government um marie explained this at
our last session
but there's what's known as the 10 20
year rule which basically gives you time
frames when you have to move
from one phase to the next as you
advance the federal project
and um we did not move into construction
within the 20-year window
and that's why we have to pay back um
any of the federal
dollars that were used for this
particular project
um so we have been gradually going to
fiscal and moving some money around to
be able to pay back
um on this project but we're still a
little short
and so um our additional need was for
two million per year
uh for the payback and um
we continue to work with federal highway
to understand the timing of that
uh and as well as um
the corridor has officially been
dissolved and so that allows us
to um surplus some of the property and
sell it off to come up with these
proceeds
and so we're working on that effort as
well there's a desire to maintain
a corridor for recreational use and rail
trail use
and so we are establishing that layout
so that we can then surplus the
additional parcels that are no longer
needed
um now all of this sounds bad you've got
to pay back the federal government
while we have to make a cash payback
with state funds
it does give us further authority to do
more construction work
so you pay it back with state dollars to
then have more authority and grow your
federal program
again so this is just something that we
keep bringing up
fortunately federal highway has not
directly asked for immediate payback um
so we've been able to defer this
conversation in the past but eventually
um we're going to be at a point where um
they're going to request that we
make the payback as required by law and
so these were our additional needs
i don't know if there's any questions on
these um but by far
and the item that we're the most
concerned about is the fleet
and that's why we're going to spend some
more time today digging into the
the needs on that side representative
petry you have a question
yes thank you madam chair uh that conway
bypass
has a is there um a system to uh
um request a waiver
um so the law requires uh the payback
um there is really no waiver process
the only latitude that we feel that
usdot would have
is to um give us a longer period over
which to pay back the funds
um but even that is not um something
that the statute
anticipates and so that's why we've been
working with them for so many years on
this issue
but if in this case usdot is just
following what's in law
are there any other questions out there
on this
okay let us proceed if we could
i'm so at this point i'll turn it over
to chris and um he'll walk you through
the fleet statistics again
so good morning um so this this is a
slide that
we showed last last time and
i just want to just go through and maybe
highlight a few things
so this is a summary that is put
together by a mechanical services bureau
each year you know so for fiscal year 21
it was
as of the start of fiscal year 21 so
july 1
2020. i just want people to understand
that because
it's a snapshot at that time that shows
um
what vehicles are in essence
at that point in time exceeding the
fleet parameters
during that time also we have vehicles
on order
that you know will replace some of those
vehicles that have
exceeded the parameters um but they're
not really they're not
they haven't been put in service so
they're not really reflected in this
chart
so as i noted last week we have 1258
units
at that time that snapshot revealed that
277 or 22
exceeded the vehicle um the parameters
for example for a plow truck um it's 12
years
and i believe 250 000 miles
so that's kind of our standard that we
use for those vehicles
um if it reaches 12 years or 250 000
miles it will show up
as exceeding the parameters now the
vehicle may still be useful uh being
repaired but as
you can expect with older vehicles the
repairs tend to get much more expensive
and there's certainly a
a cost benefit there for you know
keeping vehicles too long
is a problem so each one of these
categories
extra heavy duty heavy duty so this
extra heavy duty there are 10 wheelers
heavy duty six wheelers you know and so
on
um as we as we took that snapshot
so um column g
shows a percentage of fleet exceeding
parameters in each
in each category and then column j
shows what the current replacement value
is
for those units um in today's dollars
i want to go down to um the subtotal of
all that
so to replace all that those units is 33
million dollars
or we have identified that we need
8.9 million dollars of funding annually
to be able to replace the units so it's
sustainable so for example
the fleet is about is valued
its replacement value is 102 million um
just rough numbers if each vehicle lasts
about 10 to 12 years
you would need about 9 million dollars a
year
to be able to replace vehicles as they
reach their
their uh threshold their their parameter
i do also want to point out um
in the first note there that the
acquisition cost
that was used to pay all those current
vehicles was 73.7 million
and now in order to replace all those
vehicles
um it's 102 million so as you can
imagine
some of those older vehicles were less
expensive than they are today to replace
um
when that snapshot was taken we still
had roughly we still had with fiscal
year 20 acquisitions
were on order and being put in service
and we also had fiscal year 21
acquisition so that's where the 16
million dollar
number comes in those were planned um
acquisitions monies that were encumbered
in vehicles in certain stages of being
built and put in service but we're not
yet in service
as of and i believe this was i say july
1st but this was revised november 16th
of 2020 so that left this kind of
backlog
that we call of 16.7 million dollars
and i noted last last time that because
of
covid and the impact on revenue
we were asked to only expend
essential purchases so on the next slide
i'll show
that in fiscal year 20 we lapped some of
the equipment budget
and 21 at that point we were prepared
we were propos well i guess we were
envisioning that we would need to lapse
4 million
of the fiscal year 20 funds to
to reach our revised lapse target that
was
put forth to us since that time
we have taken a harder look at
different areas of the budget and we're
able to
meet our laps target without touching
the equipment so
i guess bottom line here we are able to
fully expend
uh fiscal year 21 budget which would
increase that
16 million by 4 million to 20 million so
in essence the total would be reduced by
4 million down to 12.
i just want to point that out um
are there any questions on this slide
before i move to the next slide
uh yeah i i have a question if i could
uh i see joe uh representative petrie
you have a question i'll let you go
first please
ah thank you madam chair uh on those uh
two wheel drive trucks uh we i asked the
same question to safety because the
state troopers used a
all-wheel drive vehicle and they cited
yes we have um we have our
um mechanical services bureau i think
last time i noted that there was an
additional cost of
several thousand dollars if we moved
forward with the um
with from two wheel to four wheel drive
trucks and
um that would have a considerable impact
because we're talking about
you know over 300 you know light uh
light duty trucks that a two wheel drive
that potentially if you convert it all
to four-wheel drive
would have um you know over a million
dollar impact
you know so they're evaluating that um
we are you know there are benefits
certainly to
having a four-wheel drive vehicle um
certainly if
the snow is fairly deep you pull off to
the shoulder it's unplowed
um you know you hate to have our
vehicles get stuck in the snow because
they don't have that extra traction
so we're evaluating it but we need to
evaluate it as a whole
and what the impacts are on the overall
budget
um you know do we spend more money in
that area at the expense of letting
other vehicles
you know go to um you know
be become more deficient and not be able
to be replaced so
that's something that we are evaluating
it but we're evaluating it
as its impact on the entire fleet
not just individual
locations and certainly safety
is one area that we're going to take a
look at but
as i noted previously now and i'll talk
a little bit more on the next slide
when monies get tight in the highway
fund one of the first things that get
that
is looked at to get cut is equipment
rather than rather than laying off
people or
you know other priority needs
um equipment is still a priority but
again historically it's been one of the
first areas that
um is looked at to be able to be cut to
to tighten um you know the belt on
expenditures so
um it's something that we'll look at
holistically but um you know right now
we're not prepared as a department to
devote extra funds
to that area um at the expense of
you know the backlog follow up
uh yes please go ahead uh right uh well
if you go down to the local uh
truck shop here on new dealership you uh
you find it's pretty hard to find a
two-wheel drive vehicle in new hampshire
you have to order special and that's
that's one issue and i will say that as
i travel around the state i notice that
your vehicle is in excellent shape you
do a good job at that
thank you thank you
i uh i do have a question um
in the 2021 budget cycle
were did all of this come from
the highway fund or was some of this
from
the general fund
so the plan 20 and 21 acquisitions were
all either from the operating budget
or the capital budget um
perhaps if we go to the next slide that
will become clearer chris do you want to
move forward
right but to answer her question
regardless of that it's all highway
funds so even the debt service
if we capitalized it would be coming
from the highway fund
okay well i was because i know in the
past we've given money out of the
general fund to
help with this not a lot but i just
wanted to
know where it was coming from so
basically
this 8 million eight million dollars
would have to
would generally come out of the highway
fund
absolutely correct i think on the next
slide it'll become evident
um we also had access to some of the vw
settlement
funds and we also have used dira which
is another program
but yes going forward this would all be
general funded
sorry highway funded not general funded
okay thank you
of course if there were general funds
available i'm sure
they could be utilized to purchase
equipment
you thank marie or if there was you know
relief dollars or stimulus funds that
had latitude to be used
that's what we said last time
equipment's our number one priority when
so this provides kind of a 20 year look
back
on equipment appropriation
and you know it's kind of history so
if you look at this chart in fiscal year
excuse me fiscal year 2000 um to
probably about 2003 that first
those first two bienniums um
the class 20 appropriations for
equipment you know we
ranged from roughly five million to
seven million um at that time when you
looked at probably the value of our
uh fleet um you could you could argue
that that was sufficient budget annually
to have a sustainable um sustainable
approach
and replace vehicles that needed to be
replaced um
and then beginning in 2004 um
and on you know in particular it got
exacerbated um in 2010 and beyond
equipment was looked at um an area that
would be
reduced um because the
there were some struggles in the highway
fund there was a mandated freeze
um in 2004 by governor benson which
basically
just um zeroed out our equipment budget
in that year um then there were other in
2008 and nine
there were internal lapses because the
highway fund was uh facing a deficit
so again equipment was cut uh by those
values
in those two years um and then this past
decade i just want to point
out um we take out if you if you take
out fiscal year 20 and 21 where we
really fought in the last biennium and
you know i thank you know the
legislature for you know fully funding
equipment
um in our operating budget in the last
biennium
but prior to that um the equipment
budget ranged from 2 million
to roughly 2.6 million in 2012
on average of 2.4 million a year so
um what happened was we should have been
spending
you know six to eight million a year and
we were only spending two million a year
that's why the backlog um started to
grow
now what we did was because of the
impacts on the highway fund we looked at
the capital fund to fund equipment
because the operating budget couldn't
sustain it so in three different areas
fiscally a 16
there was a five million dollar capital
fund um
you know approved in the capital budget
um and then
in 2018 10 million was approved for that
biennium
and then in 2020 additional 10 million
was approved in
that biennium um which was great
it really helped with you know little
you know whittle down that backlog
um however you know the debt service
on those bonds is paid out of the
highway fund
you know over um a 20-year period so
um although the upfront revenue
is great it does have a long-term
negative impact on
uh chris do we have any idea what the uh
how much we're paying an interest on
this on these
marie would you know um i can get back
to you on that
um actually in the last two capital
budgets uh they required
the capital portions to be paid back
over 10 years to be more
comparative with their useful life so
there is even a quicker
um payback schedule for that that's in
our operating budget but
i can get back to you on that on the
interest portion of
of these uh capital items so
the the the cost you said is in your
operating budget
um yes for the for the probably the
previous two
um the 5 million and the first 10
million those are in
we're paying debt service on those now
in our operating budget the second
10 million um is it will just be
starting in the 2223 budget we've spent
about seven and a half million of that
and i know treasury um that was part of
their bond that they went out in
december for
so we'll probably start seeing the the
debt service for that in 2223
and we have included that in our in our
budget
and i just want to touch on you know uh
the fiscal year 20 and 21
uh biennium um in the budget there so
um the class 30 appropriations
um was at a level that was sustainable
you know 8.3 and 8.9 million
um in fiscal year 20 as i noted earlier
because of
um covet and the impact on the highway
fund revenue
um we stopped at
you know probably march or april of um
so it was near the final quarter of of
that fiscal year
we stopped any other um expenses on
equipment
so we ended up lapsing 716 000
and as i noted earlier we had planned
to elapse four million but as we
reviewed our lapse targets we feel we
can meet
um the revised lapse target
in other areas and we can fully expend
the fiscal year 21 budget on equipment
which you know which is really good news
um
i do you know i do want to stress that
the current the department's current
budget is
um i believe 2.9 million
um the current budget proposal for 22
and 23
is 2.9 million for equipment so we're
getting back down
to that that level that is not
sustainable
and will increase the backlog so when we
look at
you know probably our highest unfunded
need um it is equipment and you know
trying to fund it at that eight to nine
million dollar level each year
so with that i'll be happy to answer any
questions the
the committee may have any questions
oh all right tom i'll let you go ahead
uh yeah thank you madame i'm just uh i'm
just not clear on
what chris what you're saying about um
the four million dollar laps and how
that
that was between this slide and the
previous slide you mentioned something
about the four million dollar laps
coming off the 16 million dollars so
representative maybe i'll try and
explain it in different words um
to see if um we can be clearer and then
chris can jump in
so when while the legislature increased
our budget
for equipment replacement in the last
biennium
because of the timing of covet 19 there
was some purchases
in fiscal year 2020 that were underway
but as chris explained
when covet struck in the march we froze
our spending
so while you had approved 8 million in
the budget
we did not spend all of those dollars to
allow us to lapse funds in 2020
this year it was the opposite we started
the year being very frugal
i'm not wanting to spend um the eight
million
we had done lapse projections and based
on what we were hoping to lapse
um there was about four million
equipment purchases that we'd put on
hold but then as we worked with the
governor and we understood where
revenues were trending
and then as marie worked with all of our
administrators and directors to look at
our laps targets
we're very comfortable now authorizing
mechanical services to move forward with
an additional four million in equipment
purchases
things that we put on hold but now that
we have more clarity around this
upcoming
biennium we feel comfortable
allowing them to purchase 4 million more
four million dollars more in equipment
than
um what they had intended to do earlier
in the year
thank you commissioner so that does that
mean that this 16 million dollar
shortfall is 12 million correct yes
yeah okay very good thank you this was
the snapshot in november
based on revenues and what we thought we
had to lapse what chris was sharing is
that
just a couple of weeks ago we've
authorized mechanical services to
actually move forward with four million
dollars more in equipment purchases
which makes the gap a little smaller
okay my my question is
on the um you call it alternative
funding i guess that's capital
is it's a mix of either capital or vw
or daira which is a federal program uh
okay
okay so where
do we stand on spending those dollars
because if i if i look at this
and you you're indicating that you had
an
additional 11 million in
2021 has that been
spent or not spent or is that
can we carry it over to 20 22
23 i'm just trying to understand
what's going on with this 11 million
yeah so i would go ahead marie i was
just gonna say about
two and a half million of that 11.6
is there's still a balance in the
capital program and we are
next week we'll be asking for a lapse
extension
um to be able to spend that in 2223 so
we are intending
to be able to bring that forward so that
so 2.5 you you've spent all but 2.5 of
the 11 million
yes that's correct okay and you're going
to
try to move that two and a half
forward to 22-23
yep okay is that going to be through a
lapse or through an actual identifying
it as
it it'll be hb 25
requesting a lapse extension so we're
we're actually meeting with public works
next friday
on our laps extension request so this is
this will be one of the items on the
list
um for our laps extensions that we'll be
requesting to bring forward
just as we were hesitant to spend
operating
dollars during the covert period there
was a number of our capital budget items
were put on hold
so we have our new capital budget
request that we'll be presenting
um to the committee but then there's
also a list of projects where we didn't
move forward in the same time
frame that we had expected because of
the revenue uncertainties
and our concerns around having the
operating budget to pay debt service
so we'll be asking for extensions on all
of the prior
hb 25 items that we hadn't completed so
that we can move forward with that work
now
and marie has done the forecasting and
we do have the debt service budgeted
okay so what i'm what i'm trying to
understand
is you have asked us to
look at additional funding for
equipment and in the past
two years you have
received 19 million
for equipment purchases if i'm you know
if i'm
reading this correctly correct me if i'm
wrong and
you still have
2.1 million that
has not been spent is it am i correct
and
what i'm talking about or am i wrong i'm
pleased
i believe in the last last two years 20
and 21
it's 28 million that we have allocated
to equipment
8.3 million in the operating budget in
20 8.9 million
in the operating budget in 21 and then
11.6 million
in capital as well as vw funding
so the way that we've talked about this
before representative
we want to get the operating budget you
know up to a level where we can maintain
the fleet going forward
so we've been talking about you know we
should be spending eight or nine million
annually
that's to replace vehicles as they
become
as they hit that sort of 12-year range
and start to be problematic and costly
to keep on the road
so we're trying to increase the
operating budget to a point that we can
keep pace
going forward and then we've primarily
been using the capital budget dollars to
try and address the backlog
that's sort of the easiest way to think
of it and so while we're very
appreciative of all the capital money
um you know we still have a significant
backlog of trucks that are beyond their
useful life
and while we gradually play catch up on
that side
every day there's other vehicles that
are aging out and becoming problematic
okay i'm just i'm just trying to uh
understand um you know where we are
i i know what you're talking about i and
i think it's good that you're
looking out there but i i need to
i have things i have to address so
representative murray you have a
question
oh thank you very much again um
so to put you right um it would be
around the 12 million dollars
to get you back to get you to a point
where you can be sustainable
what do you need and i know this isn't
going to happen anytime soon but what
what is the estimate that you need to be
sustainable assuming that you
you know you reached that point does
that am i did i ask that
clearly it's it's the 8.9 million
a year in our operating budget so we'll
get to the 12 minute get 12 million
would get you to the point where you
would
need 8 million yearly to maintain the
fleet
correct thank you yeah if you think of
it as a 12 million
backlog and then we need 8 million
and the backlog is much smaller than it
was going into the last
budget because of the support we
received from the legislature
representative lynn you have a question
yes i and i'm so i just want to sort of
follow up on the question you are asking
madam chairman i just want to make sure
that i'm so if if
if you got your for lack of a better
term if you got your wish list
we would be we would be providing
12 million dollars in funding to allow
you
to make up for
what was not provided in ask biennium's
and then another eight million dollars
for uh for what you need going forward
is that correct so it would be it would
be a total of uh
it's 8 million annually but there is
some money in the budget so it's the
difference between what's currently
in the governor's budget um on the
numbers that we showed
i'm okay i'm sorry i see i see okay so
the
total for this biennium will be about 24
million so it's the 12 million backlog
plus the 12 million we're short to get
to the
eight you know eight nine million per
year so the total would be about 24
million
24 million okay all right thank you
if i may i know that's a big ask um
i'd be happy with just restoring the
operating budget
to that nine million dollar level
um if we could if we could restore the
operating budget in each year to that
nine million dollar level so
so it's 12 million in the biennium i
think that would be fantastic
so we do not fall any further behind um
on the backlog and the backlog stays
at its current level because we've done
a great job
and you know thank you to the
legislature and and the government
in past years um to support our capital
budget request as well as
you know funding fully funding the
the uh operating budget for equipment in
the last biennium
that helped greatly to reduce the
backlog from
it was even higher is that probably
previous statistics probably showed it
grown to
35 36 million so it's been a fantastic
job to reduce it
as i mentioned i'd be thrilled if just
the operating budget was restored to uh
the sustainable level
i would be thrilled too chris so how are
you gonna get people to drive more
[Laughter]
so the next the next slide is um
it's a budget change request we have so
i don't know if this is something
you would vote on today or another
meeting but
these are some minor changes that we
become aware of
that we believe should be in the fy 2223
budget
so the first one is in our
transit bureau there is a new project
with the department of natural and
cultural resources
um and so there's a grant from dmcr
about a hundred thousand dollars um so
to be able to
utilize that grant we need to get that
budgeted
in the pro into the fy 22
23 budget um along with the
appropriation
for that uh
that's that's the first request on those
first three lines there excuse me
uh mickey do we need to uh
vote on these or do we just ask you to
make the changes since the money is
there
i would ask that you vote we could we
could just vote just to make sure we
don't uh
have any uncertainty on the action um i
just have one question on this for marie
do you know if um cultural and natural
resources has this 100 000 already
budgeted on their end or would we have
to
work with division one on theirs i
i am not sure that is a very good
question okay
so on that first one i'd say we maybe
just want to confirm with division one i
can talk to um
nancy in our office just to see what's
going on with that side of it but the
other two look
um they're not going to affect your
highway or general fund situation
in the division and they're uh we could
vote as a division today on those and i
could
get get moving on them
maybe the first one we hold off until we
the second item is also with uh down
here
on one these five lines here
this is also with our transit
bureau these are federal funds so these
were funds
that fta was provided in the coronavirus
relief bill
at the end of december and
but you know between the governor's
phase and now the house phase it was
identified specifically how much
new hampshire was getting and these are
you know directly go through the fta and
through our bureau
so there's no um you know they're
they're tied to specific
um transit agencies so we'd like to
budget
these federal funds um in fy22
so that we're able to distribute them
according to
and then the last item um these
this a new program that we just became
aware of our new revenue that we just
became aware of
related to uh alton bay lease agreements
um
so we we would like to appropriate that
the revenue and we have to pay property
taxes
um on those uh lease agreements
so we would that's why we're
appropriating uh
funds in land interest to be able to pay
the property taxes
um based on the the land that we own
there and the revenue that we'll be
are receiving so again
like mickey said none of this impacts
the highway or general fund they're all
self-sustaining revenues that are coming
in to be appropriated for these programs
marie should we bring these in through
fiscal or
i i would prefer them in the budget um
if we go you know if we go through
fiscal then i have we wait until
july and especially with those federal
funds then the transit
can't distribute those funds to the
transit agencies until we've gone
through fiscal and governor and council
and received approval so it could delay
them distributing
the funds by a month or two if we have
to wait for that
time period i don't i don't have any
i don't have any problem with that uh
mary you have a
representative heath you have a question
i was wondering if i could make a motion
um that that and my motion would be
i'll tell you before i make the motion i
just would um request that we
um approve spending authority for those
would that be okay that would be fine
with me
all right so um that said i would like
them to move that we provide funding
authority for the two
items as listed
i think i think we need the uh the
dollar value
for each of them which okay it looks
like um
sorry nine million two hundred and sixty
five thousand
five hundred dollars for
no actually it's it's i apologize it's
that
department requested increased decrease
fy 22 column
so it's 3 million 185 801. that's the
increase we showed what the
budget was before the increase and then
what it was after
so fy23 there's no increase uh that
column is all zero so it's all an fy22
for that one
okay oh it's the 3185 801 and then in
the second item it's 63
000 each year
and please add that to my motion yeah so
we need that
we need three three million one hundred
eighty thousand 801
of federal funds yes
added to the
um uh yeah add it to the dmt
yeah the dot budget is that correct
second did that hate i believe
i did okay
um
representative lynn would you call the
role
please uh yes certainly um
uh representative yeah
uh uh representative heath yes
uh i vote yes also uh representative
murray
uh murray votes yes representative petri
petri vilcius representative hunberg
umberger oh chess all right
so it is unanimous vote uh in the
affirmative
well look at that our first vote
everybody supported it
thank you all okay um
so do i have a motion for
for um fta funding
don't moved that second actually is for
right-of-way
our right-of-way bureau it's that is not
federal funds it's agency income just so
oh i want to make sure your emotions
yeah i agree oh because it's uh
carissa money is that why it's agency
income
uh no it's agency income that we'll be
collecting on
uh lease lease agreements from land
that we own okay representative the
description is underneath the accounting
line so it's that last
sorry the last line pertains to the
okay so the motion should read
sixty three thousand dollars from
agency income
is that correct correct
okay so i think i had representative
petry
and representative lynn seconded that
yes correct okay
you want to call the roll please yes um
uh representative bucco yes
uh representative heath yes
i vote yes uh representative murray
murray votes yes representative petrie
featuring votes yes and representative
umberger
vote yes all right again it's a 6-0 vote
in the affirmative
thank you all and um mickey you will
check with uh division one on the
uh on the first item is that correct
yeah once we get some information from
them then we can circle back to this at
a later meeting and
and uh vote on it okay sounds good
uh representative berger as i think i
mentioned to you
uh earlier in the week i i've scheduled
for my first covert shot at noon time
today
so i think i'm going to need to leave
it'll be fine don't worry about it go
get your shot we can't have you
we can't have you uh the only one on the
division without a covet shot
all right thank you all right i'll see
you uh i'll see you on monday
so thank you all um very much for
passing that that's
those are our only change requests um
kind of to take care of some uh
you know right regular items so i'm not
sure if there's any other questions of
the committee but that ends our
presentation
okay a great presentation today
and um next week when
going through your budget uh
with any additional questions that we
might have
um so what we're
what we're trying to do is to come
to grips with uh where we stand
on the on the highway fund
and where we stand on the general fund
um i know it was helpful
that the the governor uh
suggested that we have more money than
we do from his phase
but um unless that changes
in uh ways and means
i don't know what we're gonna do but and
also
don't be surprised if uh
the senate takes these two things out of
the budget
because they don't like to put federal
dollars in the budget
so we'll see we'll see what happens
we'll put them in
and maybe they will not notice
this small amount of money so we'll
we'll try to to get that
satisfied so is
there anything else that anyone would
like to say
do you want oh i apologize i
mean to interrupt um i didn't know if we
wanted to talk about hb2 at all
we have four or five items in hb2 oh
absolutely
absolutely thank you i uh
and that was gonna be my question madam
chair i don't know whether you want to
do the hb2 items today
or maybe cover those when we come back
in for our next session
oh because i've got to send those off
committees and i want to i want to hear
your
your take on it before i
i get something back from them so we're
ready to speak to them we can do that
today if it
is the most convenient in terms of the
schedule that's great
thank you so i know
um our items start on page 61 of hb2
uh so this is related to uh civil
liability
um the the rsa currently as it reads
um and as interpreted by the attorney
general's office
um is that we can only
get reimbursed on actual costs um
related to damage to our highways
generally what we've done in the past is
we use an estimated cost
because it's difficult for us maybe
during the winter
you know to be able to assess the full
damage we will do an estimate and so we
don't have
insurance companies and others waiting
multiple months for the snow to melt
to be you know to do the repairs and all
those things we provide estimates and
that is the industry standard with the
insurance industries is they'll
accept estimates um the ag's office is
um has suggested we need actuals
and so what we're looking here to do is
to um
[Music]
update the the definition of full and
current replacement costs
to allow reasonable estimates or actual
costs
so that that's what we're doing here so
that we can you know
receive as much back as we can get
for the damage that's done to the
highways
uh i i have a question marie does this
is this something that uh the
transportation committee
will deal with or is this something that
public works would deal with
um i'm not sure we do have it in a
concurrent uh place senate it is in
senate bill 134 currently
moving through the judiciary committee
there they have a civil liability
uh bill so um i i wanted to be sure that
it didn't get dropped so i have it in
both places
but i just wanted to make sure that the
the language does get through
yeah while this pertains to highway
infrastructure it's really
about um how insurance claims are
processed and making sure that you know
we are being timely
and providing the necessary information
to the insurance company
but then also able to receive
compensation
as quickly as as possible as well rather
than waiting as we described
for the summer construction season
so i don't know on the house side which
committee they would have
passed this bill to but it's more of a
as marie mentioned it's before the
judicial committee on the senate side
well i'll just send it to all 24
committees
representative heath you have a question
good question um
thank you um commissioner do you know
why
the ag's office made that change when
your practice was estimation
i think we have a new individual
responsible for this program who was
reviewing the rsa
okay and we agree when you look at the
language this change really is necessary
um but previously they had just
supported the department's practice
this is really updating statute to
reflect what we've been doing
i see thank you make sure that we have
the protections that we need that is
appropriate to handle these claims in
okay i saw nothing wrong with it when i
read it but i
i just didn't know who needed to take
care of that okay
go ahead okay
uh so the next is section 134
and that's the repeal of a law from 1959
uh related to sandwich notch and dale
road
in the towns of uh sandwich in thornton
that uh law requires us to pay
a certain amount of money per mile to
um provide winter main funds for winter
maintenance for those roads
um now since the block grant law was
passed
those towns are also receiving money
from block grant aid
uh to support those roads so it's really
double counting the
amount of funds that they're getting
compared to other communities for that
portion of roadway so we'd like to
repeal the law from 1959
and just continue with the you know them
getting credit in the block grant for
those
for that roadway that length of roadway
and getting that
um the funds really through block grant
that sounds to me like a public works
issue is that correct
um yes i would take that to public works
for their concurrence from a policy
perspective since they're involved
in the 10-year plan and the budgeting
around
the block grant okay thank you
uh representative murray you have a
question yeah thank you madam chair i'm
curious are they actually
getting um double funds or is this just
a matter of moving one from the other
there
or and if they are getting double funds
um they they are getting double funds i
don't know that they
realize that i think their i know
commissioner or bill cass i think has
been involved with this a little bit
more i believe the community
is aware that they're receiving the
funding from two places and that really
it's
unfair that they get additional dollars
compared to other communities
one of the things it's been discussed
with the with the town and ev everybody
agrees that you know cleaning this up is
the best case it's it's very nominal
amount
of uh it's like seventeen hundred
dollars is
based on the 1955 vlar or something so
it's
really more of an administ it's as much
of an administrative
um challenge to keep track of and uh
so everybody agrees that this is the
best the best thing to do
yeah yeah i
saw that in hb2 and i said oh that's a
that's very interesting i didn't know
sandwich notch road was
yeah i i think it's just maintenance of
of sandwich notch
road uh you know in past we've done like
like um
you know like uh
materials type of stuff a few loads of
gravel to fix some things but it's more
it's more just
maintenance and upkeep it's not i don't
think it is maintenance it wasn't
specifically winter maintenance it was
maintenance of
sandwich nacho road okay thank you
d.o.t always has interesting things in
hp2
so the next section is uh 135 which is
line 32
on page 61. um and that's related to
um disposal of real estate
so we'd like to add disposal of
add federal real estate in there along
with the
turnpike and highway funded and then in
section 136
we're asking um that
are restricted federal that are
restricted
that basically it's the proceeds from
the sale of land
related to payback so for federal funds
like the conway payback
that those funds be restricted
federal funds within our budget and be
utilized
for additional like federal projects and
that type of thing uh
currently go ahead i apologize
you don't have to apologize it was me so
you're asking for 135 and 136 to be
changed a little bit is that correct yes
that's correct
uh will you and
uh mickey get together to figure out
sure okay and then uh
what i'll do is um i will hold off
on sending that to uh
ice public works i assume that until we
get
okay
so then page 62 section 137
which is line 8. um
and this goes through sections 138 139
as well um this is related to
um unmanned aircraft so basically our
drones
um we need um we'd like to add the word
unmanned into the small aircraft or to
small aircraft currently technically the
way the law reads
um it might require us to register
all of the drones and to collect
registration fees
so this is really a clarification um
of the law and what a small unmanned
aircraft
is so that we don't you know so that no
one interprets that we need to collect
registration fees
because we have no intention of
collecting registration fees on
the drone aircraft right now there's
currently no definition in statute
we drones are certainly aircraft
but having this broad definition um it
is confusing
there's also federal outlaws that
pertain to
unmanned aircraft and so this definition
allows us to make it clear that
depending on the type of aircraft you
know a drone or unmanned
versus a traditional plane um
we would be referencing the respective
sections of the federal statutes
so i can basically send this
to a transportation committee
and suggest they enter
the term unmanned is that
is that what i'm hearing yeah the um
proposed languages
in hb2 so it's the several sections that
marie referenced
to make sure that all of the statutes
that pertain to aircraft are updated
accordingly
but yes transportation would be the
appropriate committee for that to go to
for consideration
okay and and if we'll take care of it
representative hamburger uh yes let's
ask maria quick question
on these sections that we just went
through if they were to come out of
house bill 2 would any house bill 1
modifications be required is there a
direct tie to these sections to any of
um
um the repeal of the sandwich notch and
dale road i might want to
update you know it would be small money
but block grant you know would
would need to be adjusted because we
to to account for this if it didn't if
this didn't pass
but no there are no lines tied to these
in the budget currently
all of these do have a financial aspect
to them however
especially uh with the aircraft
registrations
um we want that clarified in statute so
that we're not accused
of failing to collect additional revenue
but based on how our aircraft
registration fees are established
this if we were to apply the same
standard to drones it would be
a disproportionate amount
of registration fee relative to the
okay i believe that's it is that correct
marie
the last one is section 140 um
and that relates to the the 8.1 million
transfer to the general fund
i mean transfer to the highway fund so
this is the lapse to the highway fund
but and this relates to that 8.1 million
so the original appropriation was the 20
million
in the law um we
we've spent everything except the 8.1
million on that final bridge so
it was originally non-lapsing so to be
able to lapse
the 8.1 million and put that into the
highway fund this language needs to be
okay so
i assume you will get with mickey to
this 8.1 is already carried on the
surplus statement
so it is who accepted it as is we're
already counting on that 8.1 million
dollar support
to balance the highway fund as it stands
right now
do we need to take it out of hb2 or
no no this is uh this would be an
appropriate place for it in house bill 2
and then we just carry it as an
appropriation adjustment really
or a revenue adjustment on the surplus
statement
okay
and those are the items we currently
have in hb2 um
commissioner i didn't know if you want
if we wanted to discuss
[Music]
potential if there's a potential
increase in our lapse
whether we have some authority to
so one of the things that we have been
discussing is um
in light of both our high vacancy rate
as well as our ongoing support for the
statewide response to covet 19.
we may actually exceed our current lapse
projections
um depending on how successful we are as
we try to recruit and fill positions now
the harring
freeze has been lifted so we have
we were wondering if there might be an
appetite to discuss
should our laps exceed the projections
would there be a willingness to include
language in hb2
that if we far exceeded our laps
um as shown in the surplus statement
we'd have the authority to
move go to fiscal and move that money um
to be able to
address some of the fleet challenges
that's assuming of course that through
the budget process we don't
increase the investment in the fleet
that there you know truly be that need
that's similar to what's had happened in
the past when we showed you the sb
367 waterfall um
you know there was in those early years
before we entered into the tiffy alone
um there was money that was transferred
from sb 367 into the operating budget
when we had additional dollars remaining
we were able to use some of that revenue
for both equipment as well as some
roadway work so this is it's not the
first time that we would have
um worked with the legislature on
something of this nature
but you know if we especially if we were
to have a very mild winter
and we didn't need all of the winter
maintenance dollars
um it makes a lot of sense to take the
money that was budgeted for the winter
season
and buy new equipment and trucks to
improve our performance that next winter
so we haven't drafted any language we
just wanted to talk with the committee
to see if that was something that you
wanted us to explore
and then we'd be happy to work with
mickey and see if there's some language
that would be acceptable to the
committee
even if it's just something for you to
consider that we actually wrote this
up as a concept for you to discuss it
further and then
make your ultimate decision
representative murray i believe you were
how'd you end up first
i'm not sure but uh oops i'm not sure
but i'll be quick
i mean kovitz hurt everybody but my
heart just goes out to transportation
for what you've had to deal with in
terms of you're trying to manage these
very long-term things so i would say i
would be totally supportive of
pretty near anything that helps you deal
with your maintenance issues and if this
is one of them i'm
representative heath thank you madam
chair
and uh commissioner i i i'm of the same
mind
but what i'm looking for is you want
clarification
noted in hb2 giving you the authority
to expend lapse funds that exceed
correct we'd work on the specific
language but that is the intent
if our lapse amount significantly
exceeded
our lapse targets the authority to
go through fiscal and move um forward
with
fleet purchases using those additional
available dollars
great thank you if i could just
clarify something there are no actual
required lapse amounts we
we estimate elapsed we carry a lapse
estimate on the surplus statement
but it would be possibly it's happened
before but it's certainly unusual to
legislate
a lapse amount and then say above this
amount
x shall be used for a certain purpose so
um
this would be something new but
certainly not something
okay so marie i guess you and mickey
need to talk
okay and uh and try you know
i i understand where where you're uh
where you're coming from
uh but it may be
better to try to um
get this into the senate
in the actual hb1 because
you may know more in april
you know as or may march and that says
march
april and may as you're going through
the um going through the budget
that you know you're you know that
you're going to have more in there than
what you know about right now but that's
just
and like i said we're very optimistic
that you know there'll be either relief
dollars or stimulus dollars that might
be able to address some of these fleet
needs
um but we're just thinking of all the
options available to us
i i totally agree and uh if
mickey and marie can figure something
out then we'll
add it to hb2 um
if we yeah if we if we have the dollars
okay is there anything else that you
would
that is all that i had on the agenda
i i don't know commissioners if you had
anything else but
no i think we covered everything that
we'd hoped to present
um i don't know madam chair as we
prepare for next week you mentioned we'd
go through the budget line by line but
please don't hesitate to reach out if
there's other items you would like us to
revisit
or details that we could provide i think
we only had one action and that was to
go back and look at
the debt service associated with the
fleet
purchases that's correct and
and um i really want to thank you
for your presentation today
i think it has helped all of us to
understand where we are with the
with your part of the highway fund and
other divisions have
asked that we a lot or
departments that we allow them
to hire as long as they have
money in the budget so that if
you know joe retires and he works in
the maintenance garage but you don't
need another
person in the maintenance garage and
need them someplace else
that um you can do that
so i don't know what i don't know how
how you think about hiring or
any of that kind of stuff but i would
like you
to at least think about that and because
it it is an option for uh
for the departments uh mickey i don't
know if you want to add anything on that
or not
so for reference i think uh
representative is referring to
the authority to fill unfunded positions
and it's something in house bill 2 that
hhs
currently has authority to do so if you
look at section 21 of house bill 2
um that will that's that's along the
lines of what representative amber is
talking about
yeah so certainly you know the current
process we have our
approved funded positions in the budget
and at any
time we want to deviate we have to go
through
the reclassification process which is
time consuming
so any flexibility that would allow us
to be nimble um
and move forward with emerging needs you
know for example
that we just talked about drones in that
emerging industry we had to wait and get
a 7d
approved for that position um through
the budget
or we have to reclassify one of our
existing positions so
the more latitude we have
with respect to uh being able to hire
um the easier it is for us to manage
especially
as conditions change and um
yes we you know i hope you have
confidence in the department
given our presentations that we watch
our budget very very closely
that we would be managing all of our
payroll lines accordingly if we had that
latitude
to move forward with filling positions
as an example
the governor just lifted the hiring
freeze but we have still worked closely
with all of our
divisions and hr to meter what positions
we're posting
focusing on the highest needs first and
we are very much aware of the health of
the highway fund that's um
something that again i hope you have
confidence that the numbers we're
presenting
and truly reflect the situation and we
do everything we can
to manage within our budget commissioner
if i didn't have faith
in what you're doing i wouldn't have
offered that okay
so if marie and mickey can
uh can get together on that as well and
we'll um
we'll see how it works and i should
acknowledge
the division of personnel you know they
work very hard they partner with us but
like i said
classif the classification system is
cumbersome
and you know having to reclassify
positions is extremely time consuming
and that's what we're forced to do when
we don't have exactly
the mix of positions that we need um
so this would probably help them out in
terms of reducing the workload as well
okay is there are there is there are
there
are there any other questions for the uh
dot folks again thank you so much
uh you've done a really great job today
and i think that it it has been
extremely helpful at least to me and i'm
sure
to the the other members of the
committee so
um i'm not sure which day
next week but um i know
you will know so i believe well
pardon i believe we're coming back on
the 11th
okay okay so have a good weekend
everybody and uh we'll see you on
some of you we'll see you on monday so
take care